surrounded by death displaced
Palestinians are trying to live where
others are buried with nowhere else to
go these families have found shelter
amid the
Tombstones we were forced to leave our
homes we ended up here people started
putting up tents in and around the
graveyard the entire ra area is crammed
with displaced gens it ran out of space
we're living among the
Dead fresh graves are dug every day with
children playing only a few meters away
parents say they can't protect their
little ones from the horrors of life in
Gaza our children are shocked
traumatized they're going crazy they've
witnessed dozens of bodies being buried
the bodies returned by the Israeli
forces were decomposed and smelled awful
they are mentally and psychologically
ruined they are not normal children
anymore
UNICEF estimates more than a million
children in the Gaza Strip will require
mental health
support I'm so scared I cannot sleep my
younger brother is frightened by the
graves too yesterday a truck came and
offloaded 70 bodies and they were buried
before eyes nearly 1.7 million
Palestinians have been forced from their
homes by Israel's military offensive in
Raa they are running out of space and
nearly everything
else we are forced to live among the
dead waiting for our day to die and join
them 6 ft under what else can I say
there is no food we can't sleep
peacefully we are denied the most basic
human rights no bathroom even water
there is none Rafa is where Israel
ordered Palestinians to go for their own
safety but as the Army plans to expand
its ground operations in the south of
the strip the cemetery and this tent
camp will likely keep growing IAM gfood
Al jazer